daisy ridley was plucked from obscurity
and cast a scavenger ray in Star Wars
Force awakens
claiming one of the most coveted roles
in Hollywood she instantly became the
face of the new Star Wars trilogy her
monumental rise has been a real-life
fairy tale but it wasn't just handed to
her here's how she landed the role that
changed her life hey I'm fun and I'm
cool come along and ride with me dropped
our readily honed her skills at
England's Tring Park School for the
Performing Arts and graduated with a
concentration in musical theatre in 2010
after that she enrolled in London's
Berbick University where she studied
classical civilization but kept going to
auditions all the same
before long she decided that if she
wanted to take acting seriously she'd
give it all of her attention and dropped
out of school to pursue it as a career
one of her very first jobs was on an
interactive first aid film in which she
demonstrates how to administer
life-saving CPR in a high-pressure
situation she told reconstruction
Council UK this role was particularly
important to me of my godfather had
suffered a cardiac arrest sometime
before and his life was saved because
there was someone with the knowledge to
use the right CPR techniques on him
smaller projects believe it's all nuts
the force awakens was only released
second feature film the first being a
2012 movie called scroll are created by
filmmaker Pizza Hearn Ridley popped onto
Hearns radar through a connection from
the set of a 2012 commercial for British
supermarket chain Morrison's Ridley
regularly worked on film projects by
Andover college students and all she got
in return for her efforts was a refund
on the cost of her expenses home record
being impressed by her strong work ethic
telling the Guardian I think she just
wanted to work I'm pretty sure she was
working in a bar at the time we cast her
she was overwhelmed with the fact people
were offering her work whenever she got
casted anything we all applauded in an
effort to bulk up a real really accepted
the lead role in the short film called
blue season by filmmaker Georgia Higgins
created as part of the 2013 Syfy London
48-hour challenge Higgins told the
Guardian she was focused and giving and
open asking if there was anything she
should change or do we didn't have much
time for rehearsals and she worked
really well with that for the first part
of the film she was mostly hanging
upside down
really yeah moving up her hard work was
soon rewarded with guest parts in the
British medical drama casualty and the
comedy-drama Yungas by 2014 really had
impressed TV producers enough to start
being considered for bigger roles she
popped up as an enthusiastic shopper in
a season 2 episode of the popular drama
mr. Selfridge and she also snagged a
role in a two-part Silent Witness
special unknown while all of this
on-screen experience was a good start
for Ridley she still thought she was a
million miles away from being able to
audition for a Hollywood blockbuster
luckily for her the force awakens
director JJ Abrams wanted to cast
unknown actors just as George Lucas said
with the original Star Wars trailer J
Abrams admitted to Elle that the casting
process was scary because of the
inevitable scrutiny ahead for these new
actors he added so they needed to be
actors whom the audience could discover
as these characters not as actors that
seen elsewhere ideally it needed to be
people like Daisy somewhat experienced
but mostly new to the game nailed Ayer
Abrams took a liking to Ridley rights
away but the audition process was still
drawn-out and difficult Ridley told The
Telegraph in 2015 I was just one of the
lucky people who managed to get an
audition and he saw something in me I
thought that ruined the first few
auditions but he saw some potential I
guess and I was allowed to come back and
read again and then I finally got the
role release secured the part with her
fourth and final reading an emotionally
charged to audition that later found his
way onto the Internet
and she did it again I'm like what the
hell she was literally able to like you
know take a direction make it her own
make it better than I could have ever
imagined I I'm a crier I'm a big crier I
cried gathered a gym rat Ridley was
understandably thrilled when she got
confirmation that she'll be playing ray
but she knew that could change if she
wasn't physically prepared for the role
according to Elle to get into shape for
Star Wars she ate a diet that consisted
of lots of fish legumes and spirulina
shakes and trained for at least four
hours a day four days a week in addition
to intense indoor workouts that included
kickboxing and wall climbing with Lee's
trainer had a performance Prince with a
parachute attached to her back in the
parking lots of Pinewood Studios while
undeniably
tense that grueling workout schedule is
a small price to pay for a major part in
one of the most beloved film franchises
in Hollywood history thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]